[Música]
vários movimentos diferentes me
trouxeram até aqui
alguns deram certo outros nem tanto mas
toda vez que eu decidir me movimentar
sair da inércia alguma coisa na minha
vida incrível aconteceu o primeiro
movimento aconteceu em 2002 quando eu
tinha 14 anos de idade
o meu sonho de infância era ser jogador
de futebol e eu cheguei naquela fase
adolescente em que eu fui buscar esse
sonho eu fiz teste em diversos clubes em
são paulo até que eu fui aceito pelo são
caetano um clube que na época estava em
franca ascensão
eram muitos os treinamentos
todos os dias eu atravessava a cidade de
janeiro a janeiro para treinar junto com
os meus companheiros de time
numa época em que os meus amigos
adolescentes começaram a ir para as
festinhas viajavam nas férias e eu
naquela dedicação intensa
quatro anos depois quando eu tinha 18
anos
eu fui dispensado me chamaram uma sala e
falaram que eu não ia subir dos juniores
esse foi um movimento que me deixou
obviamente bastante triste mas que me
trouxe três principais aprendizados
o primeiro deles é a disciplina
dedicação
se eu não tivesse 100% ali eu não
conseguiria contribuir com o meu time
então eu sempre tive que treinar muito
forte
um outro ponto é o trabalho em equipe
mesmo eu estando 100% sozinho não faria
nada e um terceiro ponto é fundamental
na vida de um jovem é aprender a lidar
com a frustração e aqui foi um banho de
água fria naqueles sonho de criança
depois disso eu passei quatro anos da
faculdade é estágio na empresa da minha
família aprendendo como é que
funcionavam os processos como é que
funcionava a dinâmica ali tão intensa da
venda de pão mas ainda não era o momento
de eu estar ali
eu era muito jovem cheio de idéias
existe um conflito geracional natural
em que o mundo projovem é para onde as
coisas possam acontecer
a empresa tinha o seu ritmo próprio
então decidir empreender junto com três
amigos
eu trouxe uma marca de relógios para o
brasil o conceito era super legal é um
relógio sustentáveis de madeira
reutilizada os meus amigos também eram
muito legais mas eu percebi algo durante
o processo
eu nunca usei relógio
eu não gosto de relógio e eu cheguei à
conclusão de que não fazia o menor
sentido
ali foi uma experiência morna sem paixão
e diferente da frustração que o esporte
me trouxe em que eu me dedicava 100%
aquilo ali me trouxe uma frustração
negativa
eu não estava entregue de corpo e alma
obviamente o caminho natural foi vender
a empresa e como foi dito no começo eu
precisava achar meu caminho e o caminho
não existe o caminho se faz caminhando
então eu e minha esposa decidimos passar
um ano viajando
nós fomos para os cinco continentes para
37 países mais de 120 cidades em uma
experiência que foi realmente
transformadora nas nossas vidas
a pergunta que todos nos fazem
obviamente o ser humano gosta de ram que
as coisas é o lugar mais legal que vocês
foram e é impossível responder isso cada
lugar teve a sua característica sua
experiência o seu impacto nas nossas
vidas
então ao invés de falar de lugares eu
quero falar de experiências e
aprendizados que essa jornada me trouxe
a primeira delas foi aconteceu na
etiópia na fronteira com a eritréia um
lugar super inóspito perigoso até os
países entraram em conflito há alguns
anos atrás nós estávamos em busca de um
vulcão em atividade e já estávamos há 72
horas sem conexão de celular e isso no
mundo atual é bem com
aplicar é eu olhava pra minha esposa e
falava e aí a gente num tava sozinho no
mundo mesmo a gente não vai conseguir
falar com ninguém e ela cara quando o
que a gente vai voltar a ter sinal até
que a gente no caminho aqui na depressão
de da nakheel
a gente não tinha nenhuma estrutura
turística para dormir então a gente
dormia nas comunidades ao longo do do
trajeto e apareceu essa menininha do
nosso lado
curiosamente uma carcaça de celular e aí
caiu uma ficha
a gente estava tão em busca de uma
conexão tava com a conexão além do nosso
lado
ela nos olhando a querendo entender o
que a gente fazia ali
o motivo pelo qual nós estávamos ali ea
gente distraídos querendo algo que
estava ausente naquele momento
se não vai ter conexão adianta a gente
ficar pensando em celular
vamos curtir ali o momento então essa
importância da conexão da presença foi
algo muito forte essa menina acabou
trazendo pra gente essa foto ana medina
de marrakesh no marrocos ea gente passou
na frente de senhorim esse tanto de
sapato
provavelmente ele era sapateiro mas foi
um acúmulo que nos deixou até um pouco
sem a gente viajava com 20 quilos cada
um 20 quilos 14 camisetas duas calças um
tênis dois shorts e deu aquele senhor
que ele tanto de coisa mal humorado
resmungando ea gente se adaptando a cada
dia diferente uma nova cidade nos caiu a
ficha de que o apego essa questão do
acúmulo ele precisa ser urgentemente
substituído pelo poder de adaptação
a gente está ter respeito pela história
a gente precisa preservar a história mas
a gente precisa estar muito aberto
a adaptação ao que vem um terceiro ponto
que nos marcou muito foi na islândia
a gente estava dirigindo e de repente o
menino parou
pediu carona ea gente deu carona foi
conversando ele era inglês tinha mais ou
menos uns 18 anos de idade e nas
conversas ele disse que tinha uma grande
paixão uma norueguesa e que ele escrevia
cartas e poemas pra ela eu sempre adorei
escrever então eu logo perguntei cá você
consegue ler pra gente aí um poema e na
hora ele travou ou não isso aqui é meu
isso é caro nunca lhe um poema meu pra
ninguém
eu falei cara eu te juro a gente nunca
mais vai se encontrar abrir e ler o
poema pra mim ele respirou fundo abriu o
caderninho dele e começou a ler e
começou a 1 enquanto ele lia ele se
emocionou e não pelo poema em si mas
porque ali ele estava se livrando de um
medo ele estava colocando para fora uma
mensagem que era muito dele se abrindo
literalmente e no fim eu e minha esposa
nos emocionamos também e esse ponto eu
peguei muito pra mim porque eu sempre
gostei de escrever sempre tive o mesmo
medo de publicar os meus textos falava o
que será que as pessoas vão pensar será
que vão curtir
será que vão compartilhar nesse mundo
atual né e eu tenho uma revista que eu
sempre gostei muito chamada vida simples
eu sempre tive na cabeça a vontade de
escrever pra essa revista
eu falei quer saber vou tentar
o instagram achei o instagram
editora-chefe mandei pra ela que eu
tinha interesse em publicar um texto
qualquer o tema e ela uma generosidade
infinita falou que era para mandar o
texto porque ela é dar uma olhada 90
dias depois meu texto estava na revista
foi aquele menino que me fez publicar
esse texto foi a minha abertura foi
entender o outro lado que era parecido
com o meu que me mobilizou
em um outro ponto
pra finalizar essas quatro reflexões
sobre a minha viagem em relação ao que
nós somos e do que nós somos capazes
esse cruzamento em shibuya em tóquio é
no japão
ele é conhecido como um dos cruzamentos
mais movimentados do mundo
são oito intersecções que acabam se
cruzando no mesmo momento e toda vez que
hoje eu faço alguma coisa relevante que
as pessoas vêm me now tc por alguma
coisa eu lembro que todas as 120 cidades
que eu fui durante esse ano então
acontecendo da mesma forma sem a minha
presença
nós somos isso nós somos literalmente
grãos nesse mundão
ao mesmo tempo eu fui momentos incríveis
o taj mahal na índia por exemplo é algo
que você olha e se pergunta como é que o
homem construiu isso daqui então é não
deixar de lado nosso poder de realização
mas tudo que a gente fizer não nos faz
melhores do que ninguém ea em 2016 eu
voltei da experiência que foi
literalmente transformadora na minha
vida
o desafio de liderar uma um processo de
sucessão de transformação dentro da
wickbold uma empresa de 81 anos é
tradicionalista com um legado super
importante na panificação e eu com toda
aquela bagagem tinha que dá a minha
marca
se fosse somente pra perpetuar o legado
empresarial o que já é um baita desafio
talvez em algum momento eu me sentisse
desanimado mas eu voltei com a missão de
entender como é que a companhia poderia
trabalhar de uma forma mais ampla
socialmente
o que é que aquele 1 milhão de pães que
a gente vendia todos os dias
poderia levar de mensagem melhorar
a cidade de certa forma e aí pegando os
aprendizados de conexão adaptação
coragem poderes realização eu dê
visibilidade é um projecto que já
acontecia na companhia mas de forma
muito tímida que a origem do brasil
origens foi criado pelo imaflora que é
uma organização não governamental e que
ele consiste basicamente na compra de
produtos da floresta diretamente das
comunidades extrativistas qualquer
diferença desse processo
antigamente é os atravessadores como
eles são chamados passavam ao longo do
rio e compravam essas castanhas a um
preço abusivo desses trate vistas e o
lucro do processo ficava todo na mão
desses atravessadores o que as ongs
conseguiram fazer juntamente com a
empresa foi estrutural uma dinâmica
comercial lá entre eles para que a gente
pudesse comprar essa castanha
diretamente dos estrategistas e isso
acabou deixando o dinheiro na mão de
quem é realmente protagonista na cadeia
o que é muito legal desse projeto é que
quando a gente tá uma renda é justa e
sustentável para essas pessoas elas
possuem um interesse de se manterem nas
florestas e elas estando lá acabam
inibindo a ação de madeireiros ilegais
de grileiros e de certa forma servindo
como agentes ambientais
então a presença deles lá acaba deixando
e contribuindo para a floresta em pé
olha que ciclo virtuoso a compra de um
pão de castanha aqui no rio de janeiro
ajuda indiretamente a manutenção da
maior floresta amazônica do mundo
isso é grande essa transformação em um
outro ponto que eu queria trazer esse
projeto é que hoje em dia nós temos uma
polarização muito grande de idéias
acontecendo um lado apa demonizando
empresário o outro acaba demonizando o
ativista e por melhor intencionado que
eu fosse eu nunca conseguiria montar um
estrutural uma cadeia
de abastecimento dentro da amazônia são
só as ongs locais que conseguiram ir lá
fazer esse trabalho e por melhor
intencionados que fossem as ongs
elas nunca conseguiriam dar vazão sem o
volume que a empresa compra
então ao invés de ficar discutindo qual
lado está correto
a gente precisa entender que a
transformação ela é colaborativa cada
gente da sociedade tem o seu papel
para finalizar eu queria fechar com uma
mensagem que fez parte da minha
trajetória
a aventura se nesse processo de
aprendizagem
ele é ampla é grande estejam abertos
tirem os escudos da frente tirem o ego
saibam entender que cada ponto da vida
de vocês vai trazer um aprendizado
diferente e vai ser gostoso até os
fracassos tem uma importância grande
esteja pronto para ajustar a rota
as coisas nem sempre como lá no futebol
vão acontecer da maneira que a gente
quer e é normal
celebro os acertos e aprenda com os
erros
a gente às vezes se cobra tanto que
quando acontece alguma coisa legal nas
nossas vidas
a gente acaba nem celebrando isso é ruim
faz parte da vida esse processo de
comemorar de trazer à tona a nossa lice
dade por algo que a gente fez
e essa foto pra mim é super emblemática
procure saber o real peso daquilo que te
prende muitas das vezes a gente está
travado ali com alguma coisa que acha
que o motivo pelo qual isso não vai dar
certo a gente na maioria das vezes é a
nossa cabeça que cria esses pontos
então deixa uma cadeira prender um
cavalo cheio de potência
não deixem uma coisa pequena e inibe o
que vocês têm para movimentar o mundo e
respondendo à pergunta da palestra
quando você descobrir aquilo que te move
não tenha dúvida
você vai conseguir mover o mundo
obrigado gente
[Aplausos]
[Música]